[Music]
in a medium that's been around for so
long and that's given us so many
different tales it's a given that anime
will be chock full of betrayals some of
the most well-known characters of that
as a claim to fame in fact it's always a
major turning point when that seemingly
harmless guy turns out to be a super
badass on the villain side but the
question is which of the betrayals are
the best
honestly that's a question that's
impossible to answer given how different
people's tastes are and how different
the shows they've watched are however
what i'll be going over today are the 10
betrayals that really stayed with me
throughout the years for me these are
some of the most memorable ones from the
shows that i've watched and i hope that
you'll enjoy hearing about them
naturally though spoilers are bound now
without further ado let's start counting
down the top 10 betrayals in anime let's
start off with the black knight
betraying lelouch
moving towards the grand climax we have
one major wrench thrown in the way of
our protagonist in the midst of a high
tension episode the stakes get pushed
even higher when the black knights out
of all people decide that betraying
lelouch is to the best of everyone's
interests in the episode aptly titled
betrayal we see this scene unfold in a
heart-wrenching manner
especially given the context kogiyas is
a series filled with mind games and
people making sacrifices for a greater
goal a series filled with gambits of all
sorts and we see the intricacies of such
dynamics at play in this episode the
whole sequence of events
even cost us rolo's life and we now
remember how much of a gut punch that
death felt like the amazing thing about
code geass is that impactful moments
like this are a dime a dozen
this is barely the strongest moment in
the show in my opinion it's a highlight
for sure but in probably a surprising
take for many i think that this is a
moment that gets overshadowed by other
revelations not because of itself but
because there are so many more amazing
scenes and twists in the roller coaster
of the series
now let's take a break before the next
entry with our sponsor fiesta online
if you're up for a 3d anime rpg that's
been going strong for years
maybe fiesta online will tickle your
fancy staying strong since
2006 this anime rpg offers you a journey
to a bright and beautiful world of
adventure but what good is an mmorpg
that doesn't update and give out new
content right that's why i'm here to
bring you
good news because fiesta online will be
launching a major update
the first one of its kind in years now
this new update the biggest one so far
in the game's history
will bring with it a new level cap
enhanced enemies completely new maps
and brilliant animations without reuse
assets there's no better time to join in
and get acquainted with the game than
now
make sure to head down to the
description box and check this awesome
game out with extensive pvp and pve
systems as well as practically limitless
customizations and exploration options
this game is a wonder that stood the
test of time let's see each other in
fiesta online and have loads of fun
together
let's move from a critically acclaimed
hit to another from code geass
we move forward to madoka magicka
who else would the betrayer be than
cubey itself you know the mommy death of
episode three caught me off guard but it
wasn't in a whoa this is one
violent series way it didn't quite blow
my mind despite a lot of people citing
it at the moment that quickly changed
the whole game it's still a big moment
regardless but i found more emotional
stakes when kyubey revealed its plan all
along i'm sure some of you had an
inkling that this cute alien thing is a
villain but leading them straight to
their doom in a cruel cycle designed
with maximum efficiency in mind that
certainly got me and to add to that
cubase successfully defends its logic
the whole time with a set of reasons
that in a certain lens can actually be
justified amazing
just amazing to be fair i think that
homura's scene at the end of rebellion
was just as big of a betrayal but i felt
that it was more of a betrayal in a meta
sense
hey if not for the sudden sequel
announcement a few months back we'll be
staring at a cliffhanger movie that
doesn't have continuation
in sight for half a decade and counting
we proceed with another blockbuster with
time travel shenanigans remember moeka's
reveal
yeah who could have thought that moeka
was with sen all along not
me and certainly not the characters when
she gave her big reveal in a moment that
will continue to hornstein's gay fans
but in horror and all at how well the
scene was executed in anime form seeing
the whole thing unfold was an experience
by itself and i think this moment is one
of the peak highlights that the series
has to offer and malwareka is not as
helpless as her initial outlook or aura
might suggest
this is one battle-hardened woman and
she wastes no time showing off her chops
poor mayuri what i like about this
patrol is that moeka has quite a lot of
sympathizers
that's what's so great about steins gate
as an anime it's really all a matter of
perspective and there's really no
complete good or bad guy in the series
despite all the despicable actions if
you look at stein's gate in its writing
you can see that the whole world is
greater than you would have first
thought
helsing finds its way to the list with
walter's betrayal
[Music]
[Music]
talk about a slow burn leading to a big
reveal we can't tell when walter's
defection to millennium really started
but we all know that it's in there
simmering getting ready until it finally
leads to the big moment anyone expected
walter to be the guy who allowed the
valentine brothers to infiltrate
helsing hq i didn't i certainly didn't
expect him to be alukhan's final enemy
in the ova but the foreshadowing is
there it's been there all along
ultimately his fear of becoming old and
useless takes precedence and pushes
walter to do what he does
apparently the only way to overcome that
would be to defeat alucard
something that didn't end up too well
for him there's light at the end of the
tunnel though they say that redemption
equals death and we can see that with
the finale of walter's journey as he
meets his end
we once again see the nice guy
underneath
[Music]
one piece is such a long run that it
might seem difficult to pick a moment
from it
turns out though it's easier than i
[Music]
[Music]
thought
no seriously if you ask most of the one
piece fans what the biggest betrayal the
series has to offer they'd likely go for
the cp9 reveal it doesn't have as much
strength now with the power of hindsight
but boy was it big back then people now
still remember how they thought gaku
would be joining the squad oh how wrong
they were
cp9 really bided their time they waited
and they waited and once the opportunity
presented itself they struck
and no one especially iceberg saw it
coming imagine your closest circle
all the way to one of your closest
assistants being a spy all along it was
a conspiracy for the ages
and it rocked the entire one-piece
community will it continue to hold its
spot as the biggest one-piece betrayal
all the way to the future who
knows i know there are already some
contenders but the cp9 reveal
will always be memorable to me
okay
about a more recent contender now
rachel's betrayal comes to mind
imagine you're a guy who really sims so
hard for this girl to reunite with this
friend of yours you take the
unimaginable first step and scale a
tower of terrors a tower full of dangers
and tests and you could find yourself
succumbing to the horrors within
every passing moment that's how bomb
felt and that's how the story of tower
of god kicks off now unreciprocated
feelings hurt right when bomb finally
reunites with rachel inside the tower
and after all that he did for her in
their brief time together she drops the
shocking revelation you have to die
here heartbreaking words to hear when
you get pushed to your death and that's
right after barely surviving a fight to
the death it must hurt
on the bright side in situations like
this that awaken the strongest character
developments and changes in world view
trying to kill a person who loved you is
bad enough how about an entire clan
paging itachi uchiha
at this point it's already a given that
most people who are fans of naruto
already know of the uchiha massacre it's
one of the hallmark moments of the
series that serve as sasuke's main
motivation in defeating his brother what
kick-started sasuke's road for absolute
power was his brother's betrayal
and subsequent massacre of their clan
it's an even more amazing moment to see
play out in anime form with toby by his
side itachi began the killings and he
left
no one alive no one except his brother
who's not even spared from the torches
of the tsukuyomi what i liked about
this betrayer however is the eventual
revelation that it's not as bad of a
betrayal as it was initially portrayed
part of me still finds it hard to
justify what hitachi did but rest
assured he's not a completely evil guy
for doing it
we move on from one shown in betrayal to
another that i feel is an even bigger
surprise at third place
eisener
what a curveball this was i still
remember clearly watching this
unfold and at that time i felt that it
was genius even now
the moment still holds up and the way
the soul society arc ended with this
betrayal just feels so right
so perfect even in the whole arc we're
led to believe that gin was the villain
captain in seoul society having gone his
way to kill aizen and nearly do so with
other shinigami officers
all eyes are on this sly snake and he
completely looks the part too but
turns out the mastermind all along was
the soft-spoken and intelligent captain
who acted like a father to his men aizen
then proceeds to own
everyone before finally escaping giving
us this iconic shot that's defined much
of bleach during its early years
overall it's a moment that bleach fans
still gush about to this day
and for good reason too the setup's
great the execution's great and the
swerve was handled well enough
in second place i'm gonna go for reiner
and bertolt
remember those big burly titans that are
so iconic due to the role they played at
the start of the story what if i told
you they're actually some of the best
mentors and brother figures aaron could
have within the ranks annie was but a
preview
the reveal of rainer and bertolt being
some of the most important
titans narratively speaking was
something that completely turned the
characters world upside down what made
this moment shine for me was just how
well it was executed in anime form you
can feel the tension building up
as the two were on the roof with aaron
and they start to talk you know there's
something
big is about to happen and you don't
want to accept it but they just keep
going on
then the music hits a crescendo and even
though you want to deny it the
inevitable happens and
all hell breaks loose this is truly a
moment that showcases the excellence
that is the attack on titan anime
it blew my mind in manga form but the
anime just took the moment up an entire
notch and gave me an experience that i
will never
forget
it started as a tough call between
second and first but i'm firmly with
griffith's betrayal for number one
if you thought eisen and the rhino
bertral reveal were game changers wait
till you see
what berserk has to offer how could any
berserk fan forget this moment
good betrayals have to be game changers
that turn the whole perspective of a
show
upside down the strongest portrayals
come from our protagonist dearest allies
and for guts
i could only imagine how it felt to be
betrayed by the leader of the band of
falcon himself the most iconic moment in
the eclipse comes when griffith finally
succumbs to his emotions and gives rise
to the lord of darkness
femto's descent is met with rightful
fright from both the characters in the
audience the whole sequence
is the stuff of nightmares and we all
know how screwed guts and casket would
have been had it not been for skull
knight's timely arrival
even though most berserk adaptations
were pretty underwhelming i feel the
movie adapted the eclipse really well
the 2016 series was a disgrace in terms
of animation but this one
even with all the cgi i thought was done
pretty well
so which betrayal impacted you the most
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed the video
you might want to hit that like button
and subscribe if you haven't already you
might want to check memberships or my
patreon for the full vinitube experience
or you can head over to vinitube kai if
you prefer video essays don't forget to
check out our sponsors game fiesta
online
let's see each other in fiesta online
and have loads of fun together
links in the description i had a lot of
fun making this video so i hoped you
enjoyed it as well share the word to
your friends and have a great day ahead